- Hey everybody this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and you're watching the #AskGaryVee Show
episode 13.
(funky music)
Fun fact about the number 13 is
my sister was born on Friday the 13th.
- [Voiceover] Ruke asks,
"What's the fastest way someone
"can piss you off?"
- Ruke, you know, it's
interesting, I'm not the kind
of character that gets
pissed off so quickly.
I'm pretty much a love and zen kind of guy
for all my intensity, I
think that throws people off
a little bit in reality.
Obviously if you punch
me directly in the face,
or hurt somebody I care about
right here, that would be bad.
But overall the actual
answer to your question is
hypocrisy and cynicism.
Those are the two things
that I can't consume.
The amount of cynics out there,
though it's really one of
the funnier kind of cards
that people play on
social media specifically,
I see played less in real
life, really bothers me.
And boy, if you're
complaining about something
you actually do, and I have
some friends and family members
who play that, that just
drives me up the wall.
- [Voiceover] Vineyard
Paul asks, "How do I use
"Snapchat for a winery?"
- Vineyard Paul, I had
to use this question,
because the image is incredible.
Loved it, great way to ask a question.
If you wanna get your
question on #AskGaryVee Show,
you need to be a little bit creative
live Vineyard Paul.
All right, so, Snapchat.
Here's what people don't understand.
I predict, I'm going hardcore here.
I predict in 2016, that Snapchat will have
a number one, two, or three spot
in the most important apps in the world
from the 13 to 40,
let me say it again, 40-year-old sector.
Maybe even 45,
50, I'm,
that the 25 to 50-year-old
sector on Snapchat
in 2016 is gonna blow
away the far majority
of people watching this episode.
And so, let me give you a fun fact
on how to get good at it,
or start playing with it.
The one big creative play
that I see on Snapchat
that I see is so different
is the notion of taking
a picture and then drawing on top of it.
Some of you that follow
me have seen things
that weird spider, the raindrops,
I'll start playing with it a little bit,
I'm a big fan of that, it
opens up enormous creativity,
enormous, ooh, DRock,
some of my funny snaps
I don't know where you're
putting them D. Rock,
but and so I'll give you those images.
Yeah, so, if your winery,
take pictures in the wine
room, in the vineyard,
of the bottle, and then draw
creative things around it,
I do think that people will enjoy that,
it'll be a little ha ha.
You can do some little
contest by writing in,
I think drawing on top of the images,
because the images on
Instagram, and Facebook,
and Twitter, they all look the same.
This drawing thing is a
real creative variable,
it is a difference maker,
the attentions on Snapchat,
I am bullish on that ghost.
- Hi, Gary, my name's Kiki,
I am from Fittr, a small fitness app
available on the app store.
- That's a plug.
- We're a four-person
team, and we are seeing
a rapid growth in our customer base.
Currently we have a very
intermit customer experience,
but I'm kind of worried that as we grow,
we may have more and more
trouble with maintaining that.
Is there any advice you could give me?
Thanks.
- Kik, there's some serious
advice that I can give you
which is, if you grow,
(wood thuds), thank God,
you will make money, or
you will raise money,
those are two things that
happen when you grow,
and you will take some of that money
and you will apply it to
hiring more human beings
to continue to scale your four-person team
to a 23-person team that can then do,
obviously, in that scenario,
around six times more
engaging and intimacy.
This is the insanity that
pisses me off more than anything
which is that people think
that engagement doesn't scale.
It doesn't scale when you roll like me
and you answer everything yourself,
but it does scale when you're a logo,
or water, a league, a thing, it scales.
As a matter of fact,
I've been comtemplating
an #AskGaryVee Show Twitter account
that allows me to scale, right?
I can have four human beings
behind this show engaging,
you know, that's not me,
'cause it's a show, me is me.
And so you can scale all day long,
or you and your four-person team
willing to make the commitment
to allocate dollars into humans,
one that most CFOs and
other financial people
do not believe in.
I believe in it, do you?
- [Voiceover] Mark and
Patti ask, "What's better
"for content, vlogging or blogging?"
- Mark and Patty, this
is a great question.
And this is something that, you know,
I'm really glad you asked this question,
because I've been drilling, drilling,
I've been thrilling to drill,
I've been hoping to drill
this home for quite awhile.
And I used to address
this back in 2007, '08,
'09, definitely '09 and '10,
during the Crush It! tour,
and the Crush It! days
I answered this a lot,
I haven't talked about it as much
in the last four years, that's why we do
the #AskGaryVee Show,
it allows me to rant
about things I forgot about.
The answer is, I don't know.
The answer's very simple.
What are you good at?
You can crush it doing video blogging
and you can crush it doing blogging.
I mean, it just comes down
to what are you good at?
Are you better at video?
Since I started this show,
I've already seen 11
to 12 ask shows pop up,
of people that follow me,
of people that pay attention
to what I'm doing, and
you know, very honestly,
one or two are decent the
other nine are straight crap,
with all due respect to our
fans. I don't wanna dis,
that's not a good thing to do.
Of the 11 people that have done it,
are now saying, "Does he think I'm crap?"
Why do you think I said, "Two are okay?"
I don't want anybody to feel bad,
but, you know, some
people are made out to,
I'm not made out to write like myself.
I need editing, I need it.
I need help, grammar.
I can't spell.
I can't do it, I can't do
it, 'cause I can't spell.
But boy, can I make a video.
- [Voiceover] Drew asks,
"Do you have any tips
"on presenting your consultant services
"to a potential client?"
- Drew, isn't this a
funny little yin and yang,
one, two, with the last question?
I don't know, I mean the answer is
are you good at making a Power Point?
Can you make a video that's
like a little bit better?
Or can you sell like me, which
is forget everything else
and just walk in and close the deal?
There are, the last two
questions are questions
that happen all the time, and
here's what I will tell you,
I appreciate the kind words, the Tweets,
the admiration that I see in the comments,
I've been following very carefully.
It's been so fun.
The feedback's incredible,
I really appreciate it.
But let me tell you one thing.
What works for me does not
necessarily work for you.
So many of you do so many
things better than I do,
that it makes me want to
vomit on this football, blah,
like, you know, and what you need to do
is take a step back, ask your friends
if you're not self-aware or EQ oriented.
But you need to figure
out what you're good at.
The answer to your question,
the answer to the last question
and the answer to a lot of things
I'm seeing using the hashtag #AskGaryVee,
are very personal questions
that I would never know
unless I've known you.
I know Zak, right?
I know Steve, right?
I know is it around your neck?
Okay, I'm taking it.
Yeah, that's right, I don't,
don't worry, don't worry.
Oh shoot, this is way
heavier than I thought.
I know DRock, right?
(person laughs)
I know these characters, a little bit,
like I know them, getting
to know them more,
I have a sense of their
strengths and weaknesses,
and I would like to think
that if you ever talked
about them on a corner screen
or a conference, or you
talked to them on Twitter,
I spend a lot of time trying to figure out
how to put them in the best positions
to succeed based on what
I think they're good at.
And I could do that for you,
if I had a lot of time, but I don't.
And the reality is very simple,
you need to figure that out.
The answer to that question,
the one before, and the one
that so many of you have,
is predicated on your
natural God-given ability
or the things you've worked very hard at
to amass that skill, period.
- [Voiceover] Michael asks,
"What criteria do you use
"to determine if what you're
creating is valuable?"
- Michael, for me this is a
really interesting question.
It depends, are you talking about,
is the content that you're
putting up valuable,
because I talk a lot about that,
and you know, that is,
you know, what I use
on that criteria is
actually engagment numbers,
I mean just raw numbers,
how many people are sharing?
How many people are leaving comments?
You know, how many people
are watching the video,
like that's a very important,
very basic engagement number that helps.
But that's one baseline number.
The way I really do it,
like overall is how
many people are buying?
How many books did I sell,
because I provided so many global jabs
that you on the other side of this camera
felt like you needed to buy it?
How many great pieces of content
or best buying ability,
or pricing that I put out
for the wine that I
sold during Wine Library
that made people buy thousands of cases?
How good have I built this company
that the Fortune 500 companies
and the companies that
could afford hiring us,
and how often are they hiring
us when we're pitching?
At the end of one day, the way I judge it
is by the results that I'm looking for,
whether it's to sell some consulting,
whether it's to sell some books,
I know it's a football,
whether it's to get
people to watch and share.
You know how happy it would make me to see
every single person
what watched this video
share this video?
(bell dings)
You know, I meant that's
an important thing to me.
Anyway, I didn't do the
subscribe button last episode,
so I just want to do one big one.
(bell dings)
Thanks DRock.
Question of the day.
I've decided that I want to show up,
I'm getting very YouTube-y.
I've decided that I want to show up
on some YouTube celebrity shows.
Looking at travel, looking to the tape stuff,
looking to hack.
Any suggestions?
Who's show should I randomly show up on?
You keep asking questions,
and I'll keep trying to answer them.
(funky music)
Question of the day.
Oh, you got something?
You do have one more?
Well, then, let's go to it.
(upbeat music)